[Musik]
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
janna pareigis einzigen samstagabend
wünsche ich ihnen und alles wichtige vom
sport hat norbert könig für sich
genommen
im geldbeutel ist die inflation deutlich
zu spüren was kann die regierung dagegen
tun eines unserer themen heute
teures gas teures leben bundespräsident
steinmeier forderte im zdf weitere
entlastungen
russischer vormarsch in der ukraine
moskau meldet die vollständige eroberung
der region lohans
deutscher siegeszug in wimbledon tatjana
maria und julia niemeyer erreichen beide
überraschend das viertelfinale
beim gas benzin oder seines lebens
mittel alles kostet mehr wie können die
menschen in deutschland daher stärker
unterstützt werden darüber ist eine
diskussion entbrannt im
zdf-sommerinterview sprach sich
bundespräsident steinmeier heute für
weitere entlastungen aus und auch der
kanzler warnt vor sozialem sprengstoff
patrizia wiedemeier berichtet
es ist keine überraschung dass es in den
sommerinterviews mit dem
bundespräsidenten und dem bundeskanzler
vor allem um die folgen des ukraine
krieges geht steinmeier lobt die
bisherigen entlastungsmaßnahmen fordert
aber eine gerechtere verteilung
die pakete die es bisher gegeben hat
waren gut und war notwendig haben sogar
dazu beigetragen dass die inflation
wenigstens etwas gebrochen wurde aber
man wird die situation weiter im auge
haben und instrumente überlegen müssen
wie man insbesondere den
geringverdienern wie man denen das leben
erleichtert man habe bereits viel getan
so der kanzler im ard-sommerinterview
für insgesamt 30 milliarden habe man zb
den grundfreibetrag erhöht eine
heizkostenpauschale und das neun euro
ticket eingeführt für dieses jahr sagen
fast alle die nacht gerechnet haben dass
wir bei den unteren und mittleren
einkommen ungefähr 90 prozent der
preissteigerung durch die vielen
maßnahmen die wir ergriffen haben
aufgefangen haben im fokus stehe es nun
vor allem die hohen heizkosten
abzufedern und verändern das ist
sozialer sprengstoff darüber muss man
ganz klar ihre worte finden aber es
reicht ja nicht worte zu finden wir
müssen das eine tun nämlich alles was
möglich ist damit die energieversorgung
weiter funktioniert und gleichzeitig
allen klar machen dass wir uns um diese
frage kümmern beide kanzler und
präsident warnen vor schweren zeiten die
bevorstehen steinmeier spricht von einem
epochenbruch den putin verursacht habe
das ist jetzt ein bruch mit der
normalität es kann auch sein dass wir
mehrere harte jahre vor uns haben aber
wir sind mit unseren möglichkeiten mit
einer starken wirtschaft mit einer
vernetzung in der welt sind wir besser
aufgestellt als viele andere zwei
sommerinterviews viele vorlagen für die
gesprächsrunde mit arbeitgebern und
gewerkschaften morgen im kanzleramt
bei diesem treffen morgen geht es also
darum die folgen der hohen inflation
abzumildern theo koll in berlin denn der
druck auf die bundesregierung etwas
gegen die steigende preise zu tun der
steigt ja wirklich merklich
absolut es gibt druck von allen seiten
der deutsche städtetag fordert einen
staatlichen schutzschild für die
versorgungsunternehmen die zwar immer
höhere energiepreise zahlen müssen sie
aber kaum an die verbraucher weitergeben
dürfen die dgb chefin fordert für jeden
bürger einen preis gedeckelten grund
bedarf an strom und gas erst darüber
hinaus dürfe es dann teuer werden und
der fraktionsvize der grünen fordert die
reichsten in der gesellschaft sollten
zahlen der kanzler fürchtet wir haben
sie eben gehört zu recht den sozialen
sprengstoff des ganzen und er hat im
wesentlichen nur die wahl zwischen zwei
übeln entweder die energieversorger
dürfen künftig die sich vervielfachen
preise an die kunden weitergeben das
aber dürfte viele haushalte massiv
überfordern oder aber die
energieversorger gehen wirtschaftliche
nie knie die morgige runde an der ja vor
allem auch gewerkschaften und
arbeitgeber teilnehmen die wird sich
noch umfassender eigentlich mit der
preis lohnspirale beschäftigen also wie
entgeht man dem sich hochschaukeln von
inflation ihren preisen und
lohnsteigerungen es wird versucht mit
der teuerung schritt zu halten was die
gefahr dann wirkt die preise weiter
hochzutreiben es gab wirklich schon
leichtere aufgaben als morgen
einschätzung von theo koll dankeschön
und
das ganze interview mit dem
bundespräsidenten können sie gleich im
anschluss an diese sendung sehen
ja und soeben erreicht uns eine meldung
aus dänemark in einem einkaufszentrum im
süden der hauptstadt kopenhagen gibt es
offenbar eine schießerei dabei sollen
mehrere personen getroffen worden seien
so die polizei sie ist mit starken
kräften vor ort die situation sei noch
unübersichtlich auch ist unklar ob es
sich um einen oder mehrere täter handelt
bei einem massiven gletscher bruch in
den östlichen dolomiten sind mindestens
fünf menschen ums leben gekommen die
bergsteiger waren unterhalb des gipfels
der marmolada gletscher als sich eine
lawine aus schnee eis und fels löste und
sie mit 18 weitere menschen wurden
verletzt
noch gibt es keine angaben zu den
nationalitäten der opfer auch die zahl
der verletzten ist bislang nur vorläufig
so die rettungskräfte im unglücksgebiet
ist es zurzeit ungewöhnlich war
blicken wir in die ukraine das russische
militär meldet die einnahme der gesamten
region lohans geborsten er widerspricht
seit wochen liefern sich beide seiten
schwere kämpfe um die strategisch
wichtige großstadt lisicki offenbar
konnten moskau treue truppen dortmund
vorrücken über das kriegsgeschehen
thomas
gottschalk militärische verwaltung sagt
das schild mit dem ukrainischen wappen
die bilder sagen das ist vorbei jetzt
herrscht moskau hier gestern ein
einmarsch unter jubel das zeigen
jedenfalls diese bilder veröffentlicht
von pro russischen tschetschenen führer
kadir auf dessen soldaten eigentlich für
ihre brutalität berüchtigt hierbei
umarmungen mit zivilisten beim posieren
mit herz bei der inszenierung als
befreier
ist die stadt unter kontrolle fragt
jemand ja komplett sagt der soldat die
stadt ist gesäubert
auch russlands verteidigungsminister
shaul gut teilt präsident putin heute
mit nach vier werden jetzt seien auch
riesige chance und die ganze region
luhansk so wörtlich befreit stimmt nicht
sagt der präsident der ukraine
es werde dort noch gekämpft
vorrücken angriffe über 130 kriegstage
geht das nun schon so aus kiew eine
bilanz
wir konnten 1027 städte und orte
befreien
2610 sind noch unter russischer
besatzung hunderte wurden von der
russischen armee komplett zerstört
wiederaufbauhilfe seien nötig sagt
präsident selensky dann noch vor einer
internationalen konferenz morgen in der
schweiz
kiew selbst sei der aggressor und habe
die russische stadt belgorod vergangene
nacht beschossen das behauptet moskau
hier bilder vom staatsfernsehen vier
tote soll es gegeben haben bei dem
angeblich gezielten schlag gegen
wohngebiete
doch auch die ukraine meldet wieder
zivilisten angegriffen in slogans 70
kilometer von lisicki viele häuser
brennen viele menschen sind getötet oder
verletzt heißt es an diesem sonntag
einem kriegstag dem 130
ihre solidarität mit der ukraine haben
heute die teilnehmer innen des
christopher street days in köln bekundet
bei der großen demonstration parade
durch die innenstadt
mit dabei waren mehr als eine millionen
menschen sie forderten außerdem gleiche
rechte für homo- und bisexuelle
transgender geschlechtliche und queren
menschen damit setzte köln ein starkes
zeichen für vielfalt für toleranz gegen
hass und gegen ausgrenzung so der
nordrhein westfälische ministerpräsident
fließt
ja und den wimpeln da geht das kleine
testen da weiterhin für eine von zwei
deutschen frauen wird es bald ein großes
wunder denn tatjana maria und julia
niemeyer spielen übermorgen beim tennis
klassiker in london um einen platz im
halbfinale
die 34 jährige tatjana maria übersteht
heute einen krimi niemeyer gewinnt
dagegen zu verrennen sie kann es selbst
kaum glauben es läuft einfach für juli
niemeyer beim wimbledon debüt die 22
jahre alte newcomerin unten bei ihrem
erst zweiten grand slam turnier mit
einer famosen vorstellung gegen heather
watson spielerisch verbessert zu den
vorrunden angriffslustig und schlagstark
der verdiente lohn 6 zu 2 6 zu 4 2-sieg
und viertelfinal einzug am dienstag
durch tuning auf die andere deutsche
überraschung von wimbledon tatjana maria
die erfahrene deutsche oben wert gegen
die lettin ostapenko zwei matchbälle ab
5 7 7 5 und 7 5 am ende die wundersame
reise von zwei deutschen spielerinnen in
london fortsetzung folgt
top resultate für die deutschen topstars
an hauck und patrick lange beim
langdistanz triathlon in roth nürnberg
gewinnt wie im vorjahr obwohl sie beim
radfahren von einer biene gestochen
wurde patrick lange schaffte
titelverteidigung nicht ganz der däne
mannes detlef ist neun minuten
jan frodeno muss im marathonlauf
aufgeben
gerrit nieberg hat zum abschluss der
turnierwoche in aachen den großen preis
im springreiten gewonnen auf dem
westfalen wallach ben elf jahre alt
entscheidet der sohn von olympiasieger
lars nieberg das stechen für sich vor
scott brash aus großbritannien
vorjahressieger daniel deußer wird
vierter
und gestern erste pole position heute
erster sieg carlos sainz junior hat in
silverstone den großen formel 1 preis
von großbritannien gewonnen das rennen
wurde nach einem spektakulären unfall
neu gestartet nach einer kollision
überschlägt sich der wagen des chinesen
wang yue schlittert kopfüber über die
strecke und wird schließlich in den
fangzaun katapultiert so bleibt
unverletzt und hat nach gründlicher
untersuchung dass strecken krankenhaus
schon wieder verlassen
ja und wer an der schutzengel glaubt der
sieht sich hier bestellt ist ja so viel
glück wie schön
schauen wir noch kurz darauf wie das
wetter wird im norden gibt es einzelne
schauer südlich der donau regnet
kräftiger teils mit gewittern sonst es
ist so nicht die temperatur steigt auf
20 grad an der nordsee und bis 28 grad
am oberrhein die kommenden tage werden
meist freundlich insgesamt wird es etwas
kühler
christian sievers begrüßt sie um 21 45
zum heute journal und jetzt gehts hier
wie versprochen direkt weiter mit dem
sommerinterview mit dem
bundespräsidenten auf wiedersehen